de bares y montreal que hace un par de
una campaña en la que te cambian un vaso
de licor por contra un trago de alcohol
de alcohol puede ser vino pues una
ginebra
si llevas calcetines de lana para los
que pasar una noche y yo vi una imagen
no quise sacar la foto que no me parecía
muy ético sacar la foto pero vi pues yo
vengo muy temprano a radio canadá y
todavía la mañana es como muy oscuro de
noche y vi a un señor joven a un joven
hombre en la calle durmiendo y sus dos
perros tapándolo
para que me imagino cubriéndolo para que
no le pase nada y se calienta
la fuerza de esa imagen es realmente
valía como dice en mil palabras es la
condición básica de ser mamíferos y
aparte de la historia a mí me llena de
pena ver gente en la calle sin embargo
el amor que tiene la gente que está en
la calle por los animales
yo una vez hace no hacía tanto frío como
ayer ni como hoy pero la semana pasada
vi a una persona que estaba él con un
saquito y el saco grande tapando a su
animal acá caramba es que son los
compañeros son los amigos esa soledad
que a veces pueden sentir eso sea esa
comprensión amor incondicional mente
incondicional y después tenemos a los
otros los estúpidos que hacen lo que
hicieron con el pobre zorro no funcionó
yo tengo yo coyotes y que fue un vídeo
que pasó con el vídeo viral que pasó dos
muchachos
el motor nieve nieve motos de nieve
andando por un lugar por un descampado
encuentran a un coyote lo agarran lo
empiezan a golpear gratuita
el vídeo primero fue subido fue grabado
live en facebook después fue subido a
youtube y lo rescató el canal del vídeo
de la cbc y otros canales anglófono
mostrando la crueldad de las dos
personas gracias y después walter a los
indigentes también y ahí van progresando
y ahora pablo tiene un tema también ya
que está relacionado con una nutria
pícara podríamos decir en columbia
británica
porque realmente es extraordinaria y esa
es una historia bien bien simpática
bueno ya que habéis visto
no yo entonces es una nutria que al
parecer vivía en el parque stanley que
conocemos muy bien
además donde hay un lago enorme entonces
al parecer la nutria vivía ahí pero se
se escapó de alguna forma y se fue como
hacia el barrio chino como 33 kilómetros
del lugar y en el barrio chino había un
estanque con peces carpa así entonces
pero de peces carpas muy valiosos
peces carpas que tenían más de 30 años
de estar ahí
pertenece a la asociación desde ese
lugar del lugar
y ahí en ese lugar es un jardín un
jardín sn una pagoda tiene una estancia
en un camino sinuoso y plantas que se
inspiran de la tradición de la dinastía
y resulta que la nutria llegó se metió
ahí y caribe el stand dijo que 26 de las
de los peces carpas a un desastre para
la comunidad esto es cierto en punto de
despertar no quieren que regrese la
nutria porque más había dificultades
para agarrar porque bien si vice
mostraba es un vídeo donde la vez el ave
poniendo trampas y tratando de
capturarla porque dentro de los peces
carpas que estaban allí hay una que es
una vedette no que es la mascota hacia
la con la gente a esa al parecer no
puede serlo entonces ese se llama
madonna de gentes de todo el mundo
estaba inquieto porque no sabía decir la
nutria ya había comido a madonna
entonces pues esa es la historia así que
entre otras cosas pues no se sabe en el
momento en que yo leí la noticia no
habían capturado todavía la nutria
tapada y entonces entonces estaban
contemplando la gente de ahí de esa
pagoda estaba contemplando la idea de
mudar los peces carpas y restantes hasta
algún lugar y el acuario de vancouver se
propuso muy amablemente a albergar a
esos peces mientras que capturan a la
nutria la verdad habrá sido con un
postre para ella pero imagina que la
alegría si hubiera sido nutria pues
también empezó a pasearse por el
estanque y debe haber visto movimientos
como pablo en frente una partida por
ejemplo
es más pase la imagen de fondo de los
bifes
tienes algo para destacar hoy no
solamente la locura que genera esto el
viernes a mí me llamó la atención un
descubrimiento hecho en brasil sobre la
magnitud y la organización de las
termitas
a ninguno termitero que tiene una
antigüedad de 4000 años que tiene
extensión más grande que en la batalla
de inglaterra y que la biomasa es más
elevada que todos los seres todos los
mamíferos en el planeta y yo menciono
para detectar eso porque estaba bajo la
tierra abajo sí sí cómo hicieron para
detectar utilizaron cámara micro cámaras
que fueron deslizando a través de los
orificios de las chimeneas que sacan y
encontraron que básicamente eran
avistaba tan organizado que bien especie
de auto rutas de un ancho de 10
centímetros cuando esos bichos miden un
centímetro de un este mito y que son ahí
que son ciegos
y son están en tener sensores especiales
para comunicar entonces claro con las
antenas y la idea es es cómo es posible
que esos insectos que no tienen vista
que no tienen ni psíquico o lo que sería
aún un sistema nervioso central pueden
son capaces de desarrollar todo yemen
ante el en juego es total que además se
mantienen y además ya está organizado
por por áreas de trabajo y tienen su
manera de comunicar lo decía que es una
sociedad y que es muy presuntuoso decir
que solamente el ser humano es capaz de
capaz de hacer cosas de esa magnitud
tomando en cuenta de si el científico
que si tomamos una termita sola es el
insecto más indefenso del mundo porque
ciego no tiene defensas necesita de los
soldados necesita de la de la reina para
la procreación necesita de todo desde el
conjunto de la sociedad termita lado iu
y todos los termiteros estaban
construidos a una distancia más o menos
equiparable todos todas las chimeneas
más o menos de la misma altura
servían para sacar la tierra otras
servían como para regular la temperatura
al interior del termitero entre ellas
con las hormigas porque si no sería una
sociedad perfecta bueno probablemente a
tratamientos de derecha y de izquierda
si hay soldados entonces hay una
sociedad militarizada
reina un sistema político y está la de
antes
yo estoy cansado de parques y la vida y
para que cierto y acá no todo
seguramente habrá
hay un libro también muy famoso sobre
las hormigas y la organización que
tienen las hormigas cómo hacen para
comunicar la hielera en hay substancias
pero una secreta que las guía o sea tú
ves cuando hay unas líneas enormes de
hormigas y termitas van secretando
esa substancia y por el olor se van
guiando y van siguiendo cuando era niña
en un patio de tierra me encantaba ver
poner un pedacito de miga de pan y ver a
las hormigas que venían en fila
agarraban eso y se lo llevaban en fila y
se van como ayudando entre grupos es
fascinante verlas cómo trabajan si a los
67 años vive en un árbol algo que nunca
voy a olvidar y fue veía por el piso
como granitos como como granitos de
arroz son larvas era irak fijándose bien
era una en un combate entre las hormigas
rojas y rojas son bravas la picadura de
la cara
y un duelo mano a mano y había pues pero
era un campo de batalla increíble
bueno les recuerdo hoy para para todos
aquellos que van a escuchar el programa
en nuestro sitio web tenemos música y la
invitada de hoy es alecia cara no sé si
ustedes la conocen es una nueva estrella
pop canadiense ya actuó junto a taylor
swift hizo una gira con coldplay y fue
la ganadora del premio grammy a la edad
de 21 años este año y está lanzando su
segundo disco su segundo álbum y lo
interesante de esto y ella en una
entrevista con el radiodifusor públicos
y vice comenta justamente de que es el
es es autora escritora de todas sus
canciones y lo que lo que sobresale de
esta entrevista además es que
generalmente como tuvo éxito en sus
primeras canciones eligió el camino más
difícil en este momento que es componer
ella misma sus propias canciones no sabe
cómo le va a ir por estar arriesgando el
joven pues tiene 21 años y escuche un
poco su música y tiene una voz muy
bonita muy linda entonces esa es la
música que les
y teniendo en cuenta que murió a los 91
ya tiene una tiene para millás en
toronto tiene para muchos muy bien que
no hay mejor escuela que el error así
que exactamente y ella está dispuesta al
eso por eso me pareció interesante
destacar eso y un poco la entrevista que
se le dio en el national en sí vice es
muy interesante la joven bueno entonces
tenemos también no sé si hay alguien que
tiene voz en realidad
agradezco a guild en abril
chequeando nos y fue la que me dijo que
había un problema de sonido ya lo
arregle igual para la versión final voy
a cambiar voy a poner el audio que está
grabado completamente en el en voz baja
hiciste eso y nos dimos cuenta o no
usted no tiene en cuenta yo tampoco me
he dado cuenta si no fuera por guillem
así que muchas gracias empezamos el
programa de nuevo
muy bien entonces tenemos también
reacciones de todos nuestros oyentes que
nos envían sus comentarios sobre los
reportajes que les presentamos entonces
vamos a empezar con la lectura de
algunos comentarios no sé quién quiere
empezar yo aquí tengo uno dice sobre la
noticia y lópez obrador busca establecer
un clima de confianza tras la
cancelación del nuevo aeropuerto en
mexico y javier gonzález nunca se nos
dice saludos amigos de verse y señor
lópez orador como lo ha sido y es un
gobernante muy polémico y especial esta
consulta pública creo que no estuvo bien
trabajada y además estuvo amañada porque
le hicieron la hicieran en poblaciones
en las que ganó morena y además fue como
un número de votos muy pequeño que
cubrió un espacio de poco más de un
millón de votantes en resumen creo que
estas consultas son buenas pero en este
caso si hubiera realizado con los
involucrados no con ciudadanos que poco
o nada les afecta
es el comentario de javier que siempre
está con nosotros entrando en
guadalajara esta no me acuerdo
bueno cuarto aquí un mensaje de elba
núñez serie dice a reacción a la noticia
neurólogo experto en epilepsia ofrece
consulta gratis en español desde
saskatchewan dice el banner saludos mi
esposo desde los 25 años presenta crisis
epilépticas las cuales se manejan con un
conte x de feng y toniná y clones a pan
de 2 miligramos las características son
ausencia contracción muscular mirada
perdida y ojos desorbitados hasta el
momento la crisis no cede a pesar de
haber llevado el tx como lo indica su
médico él mismo ha llevado otros tx con
backup in gracias por su ayuda dice él
va núñez garcía que será un proyecto de
es un proyecto de un médico canadiense
mexicano que este especialista
justamente en este tipo de enfermedad y
que ofrecía consultas gratis
en castellano para gente de todas las
américas que quisieran consultarlo pues
de eso se trata entonces pueden
consultarlo ahí en el reportaje en la
entrevista está la dirección para con
sus pares para con lo que me gusta
escucharse dos veces yo tengo aquí un
comentario sobre el ejército de canadá
le levantaría requisito de ciudadanía
para aumentar sus efectivos y hay tres
comentarios uno de hugo que dice cómo
puedo pertenecer otro de juan sebastián
millán álvarez que dice soy colombiano
soy activo en el ejército colombiano
cuáles son los requisitos y luego hubo
otra vez dice soy mexicano y tengo 17
años puedo pertenecer 17 años muy chico
muy chico muy chico solo es algo que
aquí se admite en el ejército canadiense
a estudiantes cuando terminas el
secundario y quieres hacer por ejemplo
una carrera que no sea militar
necesariamente pero puede ser medicina o
cual ingeniería lo que quieras
vas a entrar al ejército el ejército te
ayuda a pagar los estudios para después
estás obligado cuando te recibe a
devolver entre comillas por el ejército
un x cantidad de tiempo que permitió que
vos te tuvieras tu profesión sin real
gestores puede entrar a partir de los 12
años 12 años aquí es decir hacer más
calendario a los cadetes que ver eso
también existían américa latina los
cadetes y también en otro tipo de
escuelas son los cadetes yo conozco
particularmente tengo un par de sobrinos
que están en los cadetes del aire cómo
funciona eso que supone una entre
comillas escuela militar tienen un
montón de actividades es gratis el fin
de semana sería de semana el fin de
semana y tienen salidas es realmente un
programa fantástica quien nunca pekín en
quebec canadá está federal tiene salidas
a lugares que tienen que ver con la
aviación personas cadetes del aire les
enseñan a marchar les enseñaron un
instrumento musical les enseñan historia
se les enseñan un montón de cosas y les
dejan una puerta abierta para que así si
en el futuro quieren pertenecer pueden
hacerlo
y es gratis todo está digamos hace
juntan fondos una vez al año vendiendo
rifas y tal y los chicos pueden aprenden
tiro también aprenden un montón de cosas
que tienen que ver con la parte militar
militar y otras que no tienen que tiene
que ver con la parte social hacen
trabajos sociales de la gente es
realmente extraordinario en la labor que
hacen estas personas de acuerdo
separándolos para que idealmente se
enrolen al ejército canadiense sin
seguro pero según porcentajes ahora en
este momento no me acuerdo muy bien pero
hay muchos de los que estudian
aprovechan esa oferta del ejército para
tener profesión es claro que después se
retiran se es el carro donde desde
muchos pilotos de aviones a pelotas
militares que luego pasan a la aviación
sino amércia agro en realidad ahí es
diferente porque los pilotos para entrar
a la visión civil necesita cierta
cantidad de horas de vuelo y lo que hace
justamente es enrolarse para poder estar
en el cuerpo de aviación para poder
cumplir con las suelas de vuelo
terminadas de todas maneras beneficia a
ambas partes
cuando están en el ejército también
están participar por ejemplo conozco
aquí en grada de un programa con una
persona que trabaja en la parte de
reparación de aviones de donde reparan
aviones y que tienen una parte de
testeos de aviones y las personas que
están avión son chinos porque son
traídos específicamente para eso porque
en realidad porque el gobierno chino
tiene un arreglo de arreglo con el
gobierno canadiense entonces vienen
prueban que están los aviones y después
ellos tienen que volver pero en el caso
de los chinos tiene que trabajar toda su
vida para el gobierno chino
igual es exactamente que no es tan malo
para los chinos hay muchísima gente que
viene porque estas personas no tienen
trabajo durante 50 años no eso desde el
espionaje deben ser muy
con los dedos también sobre todo ahora
ahora para la espionaje no es necesario
oír a meterse adentro de una empresa uno
va por internet y encuentra cosas y uno
dice estuvo así como vos que sos un
experto estuve leyendo el no leí el no
entré a leer el texto leí el título y de
en un radio canadá y decía todos los
sitios pueden ser hackeados
absolutamente todos los sitios sólo
luchan no hay ninguno que sea
infranqueable todos los sitios todos los
los teléfonos celulares todas las
contadas horas ya desde el momento en
que el mandamás de facebook hace una
entrevista y en su computadora personal
tiene tapada la cámara con una cinta
negra es porque cualquiera puede entrar
ahí a ver y estamos hablando de mark
zuckerberg que tiene la infraestructura
como para protegerse sin embargo tiene
una cinta de pando porque cualquiera que
tenga la capacidad suficiente puede
entrar su mano
y ver desde su máquina lo que está
pasando así que cualquiera y ahora iba a
ser un artículo esta semana pero
finalmente no lo hice porque es
demasiado complicado es más hay cosas
que yo todavía no entiendo que tienen
que ver con la inteligencia artificial y
las brechas de seguridad en la
inteligencia artificial se puede engañar
fácilmente a la inteligencia artificial
caramba bueno vamos con algunos de los
temas me gustaría destacar después
seguimos con la lectura de algunos
hechos o temas que hemos cubierto tal
vez en noticias que me parece
interesante destacar sin que sean los
temas de la semana pero por ejemplo
pablo vos hiciste una noticia que a mí
me es como que me sorprendió pero ya no
me llama tanto la atención en haití y la
gente sale a la calle sigue saliendo
porque hay manera
desde hace ya cierto tiempo que hay
frecuentemente manifestaciones en haití
y ahora últimamente nuevamente haití se
encuentra pues a fuego y sangre ya van
varios muertos
y las manifestaciones son sobre todo
esta vez jóvenes quienes salen a
manifestar y esto en signo de protesta
harto están están hasta la coronilla por
toda la corrupción que existe por todo
por todos los problemas y aseguró
específicamente exacto que esté
agrediendo explicaciones ellos piden
explicación por un programa en
particular que fue creado hace mucho
tiempo por el fallecido presidente hugo
chávez un problema se llama petrocaribe
que permitía permite finalmente a países
del caribe y de américa latina' comprar
petróleo venezolano a un precio especial
para razonables y entonces en el caso de
haití lo que sucede es que había un
fondo que fue dedicado por petrocaribe
para para haití y hubo un desfase cuando
estamos hablando vamos hablando aquí de
unos dos mil millones de dólares y que
no se sabe qué no
sabe por dónde pasó ese dinero bueno
algunas sospechas hay porque se dice que
en el 2016 y en el 2017 hubo
investigaciones de parte del senado
haitiano que llegaron apuntaban a
políticas a varios a varios exministros
del partido actualmente en el poder pero
finalmente eso no llegó a ninguna
acusación formal me hace acordar un poco
también cuando fue él el que la gran
catástrofe también en haití donde se
dice mejor
el temblor recaudación así que los
clinton estaban implicados en esto
habían no sé cuánto de uno no los acusó
a ellos pero digo a veces junto de
muchísimo dinero la fundación clinton
que era que era creo que era y también
se hablaba de que ese dinero pues no
aparecían hoy haití sigue cada vez más
pobre los haitianos cada vez más pobres
y sufriendo de la pobreza ahora bien
este escándalo de petrocaribe es un
estándar lo que implica a cuatro
presidentes y a calais gobiernos habría
que habría que eliminar la presidencia
en haití
ese nombre
un comité que dirija al país formado por
mujeres por gente de las organizaciones
populares civiles no sé por qué cuatro
presidentes y es mucho rufo si estaba
pensando que vos también tocaste un tema
que me pareció importante destacarlo y
que tiene que ver con la provincia de
ontario que recientemente eligió a un
primer ministro de la derecha del
partido conservador ump
y que quiere que la provincia sea un
lingua anglófona aparentemente
justamente con la hay que decir con la
con la brand yendo a la bandera del
déficit presupuestario ha decidido
cortar el gobierno de ontario los fondos
para las instrucciones y los servicios a
la comida francófona en ontario que son
como 600 mil son muchos son 740 mil más
o menos según la asociación francófona
de ontario y esto implica por ejemplo
recortes no solamente por ejemplo se
cancela la creación
los estudiantes
e instituciones como por ejemplo
dedicadas a la enseñanza y la difusión
de publicaciones para niños en francés
está desde la compañía la compañía de
teatro más antiguas en francés +3
millones de dólares que se cortan y
básicamente uno se pregunta si alguien
no conoce que a cómo suena un piano
entonces es fácil deshacerse del piano
exacto y creo que el problema de oxford
sobre quién además sobre esfuerza lee un
artículo muy interesante sobre su
vínculo con el narcotráfico en ontario
del actual de la familia fueron la
familia que su hermano ya había sido
alza la mano era primero falleció de
hecho y que era alcalde de la ciudad del
torcal desde la ciudad de toronto que
también había se había hablaba de
conexiones bueno se hablaba de que él
era tenía problemas
dejando de lado creo que lo importante
es destacar
quizá uno tiene que plantearse si
realmente tiene la las herramientas como
para entender el valor de la francofonía
notario que nace provincia más populosa
del país la es además la provincia más
gruesa en un país oficialmente bilingüe
exacto y la reacción no solamente en
ontario porque por ejemplo está una
diputada una diputada de su propia el
partido conservador demandas y marc
injustamente denunció estos recortes el
alcalde que ve que también los denunció
pero no la ministra de la francofonía de
la provincia no la misma porque dice que
eso va a pasar ahora al ombudsman molón
y que es la hija de ryan marrón ya al ex
primer ministro de canadá el próximo el
propio primer ministro ya centro dijo
que iba a abordar el tema de estos
recortes porque es una obligación del
gobierno federal mantener los servicios
a la francofonía estar y básicamente
está tocando un derecho fundamental
finalmente sí yo creo que personalmente
él quizás no llega a entender tampoco lo
que es de mantener el bilingüismo
o si lo ve al valor pero no le interesa
esa es la parte que a mí me da y uno de
los parte del interese tampoco que
digamos trate de deshacerse para que
intervenga el gobierno federal y ponga
el dinero el gobierno federal la parte
que a mí más me angustia es que los
medios anglófonos en ontario casi no
hablaron muy desapercibido pero que eso
pues no no no no tiene nada que ver con
ellos los medios que pasaron por alto
eso a un punto tal que un periodista de
aquí de montreal que se llama patrick la
cas y así escribió un artículo en inglés
para decirle el que pasa claro cuando se
habla de que se arma todo a tempestad
sobre el uso del italiano en la en el
menú de un restaurante en quebec y que
la oficina de la lengua francesa dice
que tiene estar en francés todo el mundo
salta como un asalto a la lengua inglesa
exacto se pregunta inclusive
cómo habría reaccionado en canadá inglés
aquí en quebec se hubiera hecho se le
hubiera servido la misma medicina a los
anglófonos que son más o menos la misma
cantidad de los bonos en proporción de
francófonos en ontario cómo ha
reaccionado el canal a inglés si lo
hubieran cortado a mckeel no se hubieran
cerrado los varios libros o los teatros
anglófonos y entonces un debate
interesante que todavía no sabemos cómo
va a terminar
no solamente para decir que más fred
echeverría dice la salud al jugador y
dice que hoy se está celebrando la
fiesta de la lectura
pérez ante y nos muestra en su foto de
perfil está utilizando una
una chamarra de radio cara internacional
no le puedes sacar no lo puedes sacar la
foto y ponerla sí sí el avance
qué ironía justamente en este en un
viernes en el que el ministro de
educación de ecuador renunció al cargo
indicando justamente que no está de
acuerdo con los recordar las medidas que
está tomando la lengua y no pidiendo la
renuncia de todos los ministros entonces
los estudiantes salieron el lunes en las
calles y había un cartel enorme decía
que justamente son medidas neoliberales
las que estaba pensando mente y sobre
todo que tocan apuntan al educar a
educación a la privatización de la salud
ahí tenemos en la pantalla
va a poner un resto de envidiosos por
ahí
si nuestros otros oyentes de radio
canadá internacional que lo puedan
mostrar pónganlo y nosotros lo
difundimos tengo un tatuaje
vale todo bueno vamos entonces ahora
porque tengo miedo que nos falte el
tiempo y no tengamos para tiempo para
conversar sobre los temas que destacamos
cada uno de nosotros esta semana voy a
empezar con vos leonardo con un tema que
está en todo el mundo estuve viendo no
hay país que se salve es el black friday
el viernes negro y el y otra cosa más
gracias a silver volver manda el
ciberlunes lunes y ver de qué se trata
todo esto y qué es lo que hay que tomar
en cuenta con esta con estas en realidad
es el reflejo de la locura por
consumista de nuestro mundo de hoy y es
evidentemente una locura lo que pasa por
lo menos en él
digamos méxico eeuu y canadá
realmente se vuelve una locura y en
realidad el black friday
es contagiosa sí sí sí y en realidad no
comienza hace un par de años sino que
viene desde los años 50 es cuando los
vendedores al detalle son los que
empiezan con esta especie de promociones
aprovechando el día de acción de gracias
que es feriado en eeuu y abriendo los
locales ese día con un montón de
descuentos lanzando las ventas navideñas
en realidad
[Música]
sobre todo cuestiones electrónicas que
se venden mucho y aparte hay promociones
que son realmente que valen la pena pero
la locura que se desata es lo que
charlamos antes de empezar el trabajo o
sea ir a comprar y salir con 5
televisores 6 10 y 60 pulgadas es
evidentemente para la reventa porque si
no no tendría sentido
se le ocurre y en realidad no es el
problema comprado cinco televisores del
problema es como
golpeando gente entrando sin un archivo
con leonardo hubo en eeuu una persona
muerta en un momento dado porque pasaron
por en el 'boxing day' que todavía no se
ve en acción de acuerdo haber leído en
algún momento que en canadá no existía
este friday viernes negro pero en un
momento dado se dieron cuenta aquí en
canadá los comerciantes de que
muchísimos canadienses cruzaban la
frontera para ir de compras a eeuu en
este bien y ellos perdían acá esa que se
fueron un poco a poco metiéndose y hoy
estás hace que las grandes estas tiendas
de en canadá también estén pues ir ahora
tiene que ver con las cifras porque
bueno para consumidores que comprar
artículos promocionales en el viernes
negro aumentó el 31 por ciento cualquier
año en el 2017 caramba muy bien con
respecto al año anterior según el sitio
estatista puntocom en canadá al gasto me
de compra
para la fiesta de fin de año en el 2017
fue de mil 622 dólares per cápita
promedio carambas muchísimo dinero
contracción se mueve aquí mucho dinero
entonces lo que dejamos en el artículo
que está en el sitio recinto sea barra s
qué es lo que hay que tener en cuenta en
las compras durante el black friday el
cyber monday
cuáles son los consejos desde parte de
las asociaciones de protección al
consumidor las cosas que hay que tener
en cuenta para no caer en las mentiras y
también hago referencia a dos artículos
anteriores donde hablábamos de las
ciberestafas porque aumentan a medida
fecha y hay un artículo tuyo también que
tiene que ver con la compulsión de la
compra si los compradores como así que
todo eso estás en una es una apoteosis
de la
del consumo y justamente el resultado
alguna forma de este consumo que ha
hecho que la unión soviética porque se
con la propaganda estaban las tiendas
vacías había colas para comprar pan
etcétera y aquí es justamente lo opuesto
totalmente opuesto pero al mismo tiempo
hoy día también es el día de no comprar
nada
by nothing hoy es el día de hoy puesto
justamente él escucha hablar muy bien la
promoción va a funcionar tendrían que
haberlo puesto entre mañana en otras
billeteras de entrar a caramba bueno vos
vas a hablar de un premio de literatura
extraordinario porque esta persona lo
ganó por segunda vez en canadá y además
es de las minorías un edil ignora de
origen africana canadiense de padres
ghaneses ya tiene 40 años es sí
sí
eso ella vive en las praderas estudio
nació en alberta y esta es su segunda
justamente sucedió hace 67 años atrás
con el hablar y ahora con washington
black
es una joven autora de raíces africanas
y esto quizá es un reflejo de lo que
está pasando en que nada porque lo más
interesante de la literatura está siendo
escrita por gente que nació en otras
partes está quinto y que nació tiene 55
años nació en vietnam enjoy y mean
sitting está rawi hage que es un libanés
que vive en montreal microondas y que
viene de colombia y blanca vive en
toronto él está rohinton mistry que
nació en bombay que tiene 60 50 y tantos
66 años entonces esta es la riqueza de
la literatura se puede
y justamente lo interesante es que van a
presentar elementos a partir de la
historia y de la mirada y de la mirada
exterior por ejemplo lógicamente mystic
compara canadá con la india no claro es
súper interesante lo que están haciendo
así en todo eso es en todo cualquier
país del mundo ruso donde hay
inmigrantes escritores trae en su bagaje
también y sus historias no en eeuu no en
eeuu porque se fijan por ejemplo tomen
cualquier colección de literatura
contemporánea estadounidense van a ver
que hay poco muy poca diversidad
comparado con la mantenida dices
en el origen de los autores por ejemplo
de la misma forma por ejemplo que uno de
los unos de las tragedias de la
literatura quebequense por ejemplo es
que cuando agarras un libro una
antología de la polícia quebequense no
está a leonard cohen no está no están
los autores ingleses entonces alguna
forma en que nada tiene esa ventaja de
que hay de una quizás tenga que ver con
esta idea de que el canadiense es más
bien discreto y deja que otros cuenten
su historia no lo sé es una
pero básicamente para acabar dice que lo
importante es que la literatura puede
dar voz a los subalternos a los que no
tienen voz y recuperar que las voces que
la historia ha callado entonces lo cual
mostró una una posición enfrentada entre
la literatura y la política muy bien
gracias rumbo me escuche parte de la
entrevista que hizo si vice con ella y
decía por ejemplo recibir el premio
discúlpenme no pensé nunca que lo iba a
ganar por segunda vez no preparen ningún
discurso evidentemente así que vale el
doble
pablo vos estás se nos va a hablar de
pues de la unam canadá exacto de la
escuela en particular no hay particular
que marcó la historia de méxico la
historia contemporánea de méxico estamos
hablando de de la masacre de tlatelolco
en 1968 sólo una semana o diez días
antes de los olímpicos o recuérdense que
en ese en el 68 hubo los juegos
olímpicos en méxico y en el mundo
sí sí entonces en el 68 en octubre del
68 hubo una manifestación de estudiantes
y que fue violentamente reprimidas las
cifras varían se habla de entre 200 y
300 s es una deuda como dice mi
entrevistado que es gerardo familiar
ferrer secretario técnico de la unam
canadá que es una deuda que el gobierno
mexicano tiene en ella con el pueblo de
decir la verdad que sucedió algunos
dicen que fuentes 200 y 300 muertos las
autoridades el gobierno en esa época
habla de tres muertos y unos y algunos
heridos cuatro muertos y veinte heridos
dice de las fuentes gubernamentales
mientras que la policía habla de 50
muertos y decenas de heridos
entonces pues nunca quedó claro cuánto
cuántos muertos hubo en la masacre de
tlatelolco el hecho es que en este se
está cumpliendo el 50 años es el 50
aniversario de esa masacre y muchos de
los estudiantes que murieron allí entre
otros venían de la unam de la
universidad nacional autonoma de mexico
la unam ha organizado durante todo el
2018 una serie de eventos que para
conmemorar esa masacre y hay que
recordarles a nuestros oyentes que aquí
en canadá en gatineau existe una escuela
de extensión universitaria de la unam
mixta que en canadá y es esta escuela de
extensión universitaria la que organizó
una exposición que se llama hacia hace
50 años el m 68 como lo conocen en
mexico esta masacre m 68 y la unam
entonces pues son fotos de archivo de la
universidad nacional autonoma de mexico
que se presentan en esta exposición y
que bueno que conmemora ese evento
trágico vamos a cortar ahí porque si no
no te queda tiempo aquí para presentar
tu aislada el entrevistado muy bien ah
bueno yo tengo un tema que ustedes
recordarán cuando fueron las elecciones
en brasil y recientemente como la
utilizo agencia de eeuu que utilizaban
más facebook para las elecciones
brasil se utilizó el whatsapp de manera
ilegal o mandando mensajes que no eran
porsche en cadenas impresionantes donde
denigraban al candidatos a dar en fin
una serie pone en este momento están
utilizando toral en brasil el whatsapp
como instrumento de delación en las
redes sociales y el objetivo es que si
quiere implementar crear una especie en
las universidades es universidades sin
como dicen ellos sin partido
son universidades en lo que quieren es
universidades sin ideología de
izquierdas sobre todo que no haya más
debates que no haya más discusiones como
se hacen veces es la el semillero
universitarios y desee son o bruixa d'or
general es exactamente entonces el tema
es que están utilizando whatsapp
diputados el recientemente electos están
utilizados donde se le piden a los
estudiantes de derecha que manden
mensajes y que firmen a profesores que
tienen una ideología de izquierda en sus
cursos
es que quieren dar cursos de clase de
educación sexual simplemente que se los
denuncie y el tema es que eso se difunda
en las redes sociales y entonces están
creando miedo entre los por el cuerpo de
profesores y ya y en la entrevista fue
la hice acá con julián durazo germán que
es un profesor de la universidad de
quebec en montreal y el donde él decía
que ya un profesor fue atacado en las
redes sociales y en whatsapp por haber
mostrado una película sobre la dictadura
brasileña a universitarios entonces es
un tema que va a continuar por supuesto
porque recién empieza en brasilia hasta
de brujas que quedan diez segundos chau
gracias
si mantengo el gobierno y todos los
viernes aquí en la cita así es hay
estadios